former president Donald Trump was in Las
Vegas today telling campaign volunteers
that Nevada is a tough state to win but
he believes it's Republican his visit
comes as we're still more than a year
away from the 2024 presidential election
8 news now reporter Joshua peguero was
at the event and has a response from
Democrats as well
the former president spoke for 40
minutes inside a church near Craig and
Rancho Donald Trump railed against the
media in the 2020 election calling it
rigged we have broken borders and we
have rigged elections and you can't have
either of those two if you're going to
have a country if you're going to have a
great country you can't have any of that
this event was only open for campaign
volunteers but that didn't stop folks
from lining up for hours on Friday Trump
was campaigning in Iowa where Florida
Governor Ron desantis's wife was also
campaigning DeSantis is vying for the
GOP Presidential nomination he took
several shots at the Santa Saturday
telling the crowd the Santa's will cut
Medicare and Trump also called President
Biden corrupt and we're going to win
that election in numbers
the likes of which I think nobody has
ever seen before I see it two Democratic
Nevada lawmakers congresswoman Dina
Titus and Congressman Stephen Horsford
criticized president Trump's event at
this church calling him a threat to
democracy I was at the U.S Capitol on
January 6th when people literally
attacked not only the U.S Capitol
building but our very institution of
democracy Titus accused Trump of rolling
back several rights during his 10 U.S
president including the rights and
abortion Trump appointed the three
conservative justices who when he
appointed he said they were going to
roll back Roe versus Wade and that's
exactly what they did Trump who's under
investigation indicted twice already did
not talk much about his legal issues but
he criticized the Department of Justice
calling it quote the department of
Injustice Joshua preguero eight news now
today Iowa Republican leaders chose to
hold their first in nation caucus on
January 15th marking the first time GOP
voters will get to vote for a candidate